We're very close to understanding how to solve our problem--
how to prevent buildings from getting struck by lightning.
Let's take a look. Here's our cloud overhead. And the bottom of that cloud is negatively charged.
That induces some positive charge on the ground,
and this leads to some complicated pattern of electric field.
Okay, so we've got these buildings. We know that they're at risk of being struck by lightning.
In fact, well, there's a lot of ways to explain what's going on with this lightning.
It's a very complicated subject.
But one thing that's going to happen is a little bit of charge
due to this negative charge will be induced on the roof.
And since the tip of this roof is a little closer, a little more charge will be induced there
and a little less over here and that's going to modify the electric field.
It's going to make the electric field around here a bit stronger
and quite a bit stronger here and even a little bit stronger over this building.
Now, can you tell me which of these three buildings is most likely to get struck by lightning?